in run-down buildings across Leicester
there are hundreds of textile factories
inside a maze of separate workshops
where our cameras in question
from the outside it's hard to tell
what's going on broken windows are
patched up with cardboard the workers
inside largely shielded from view there
are claims of illegally low pay most
workers we asked gave the same answer
[Music]
this man was filming us a few of the
more openly Universal he claimed to work
for the building's landlord and didn't
want us there there are some quite
serious allegations for business owners
to answer maybe they do versus verify
representative will get truly are to the
press what we're trying today many
workers are frightened this woman didn't
want us to reveal her identity we've
reduced her words how much do you get
paid six five five fifty per hour yeah a
little money little money
the industry is fueled by fast fashion
many factories in Leicester supply
online retailers including boohoo and
its subsidiaries through who says it was
called by the allegations and
blending independent auditing specialist
to make unannounced inspections the
owner of this factory says he was
visited by officials he checked my all
the books and like do they want to be
the face ba ye how much do you pay the
staff here really long ways for
everybody
allegations of exploitation of textile
workers
this woman worked as a fashion designer
in one of the factories back in 2007 it
was just not a nice place to be
I was probably say I'm scared of them to
be honest for all the hours that I'd
worked it worked out too they were
paying me about four pounds just over
four pounds an hour she reported it to
the police that was 13 years ago annoyed
I feel really annoyed after I reported
it at the time left Asha police say
they're unable to comment on the
allegation without further details a
multi-agency investigation into
exploitation is now underway light is
now being shown upon an appalling litany
of abuse and I'm glad to hear that the
National Crime Agency is now conducting
an investigation it's got a lot of power
to bring in various agencies to start
the work of an investigation or into
this modern-day slavery is all around as
it's in every town and city in Britain
and indeed in our rural areas as well a
conspiracy of silence is being blamed
for abuse of vulnerable workers over
many years Becky Johnson Sky News Lester